[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis wells
heute gibt es eine silvester torte ich
habe eine motiv torte gemacht
zum thema ja so ein bisschen ähnlich im
wunderland eigentlich nichts das
starttor mutmacher und silvester ist bei
uns eigentlich so ein großes thema muss
ich ehrlich sagen die letzten jahre
verschlafen wir es eigentlich möglich
sein
das war ja das war vergangen
auf jeden fall jedenfalls wenn es früher
auch gerne mit der familie gefeiert und
es war immer echt schön aber irgendwie
seitdem wir kinder haben schlangen
berlin umziehen bin ganz ehrlich im bett
um zwölf mal kurz auf was da alles
passiert und schlafen wieder weiter ja
dieses jahr habe ich mir gedacht komm
jetzt machen wenigstens ne schöne torte
vielleicht für euch zu nachmachen und
daraus ist diese torte entstanden
ich habe jetzt hier unten eine torte mit
etwas auch orangenschalen abtrieb ich
habe waldfrucht mit drin und eine
vanillecreme und hier oben eine
schokoladentorte die steckt unter dem
hut und ja vom thema her hier oben habe
ich diese schöne uhren die zahnräder und
hier unten finde ich ganz schön diese
tafel optik also diese kreidetafel optik
da kann man einfach was drauf schreiben
was man möchte steht zb 2017 und liebe
glück man kann seine vorsätze
draufschreiben seine vorsätze familie
gesundheit ist uns ganz wichtig und
deswegen steht das mit drauf genau die
lkw nicht essen
die kamera schon essen die schon aus
modellierte roulade aber ja ich habe ein
paar fragen sehr hart
ja für die torte ich hab's ich habe mir
die arbeit auf zwei tage aufgeteilt und
hab dann eben erst die dekorationen
hergestellt die tortenböden gebacken und
hab dann am nächsten tag dann die torte
im prinzip dekoriert und fertig gestellt
das heißt falls ihr nicht einen ganzen
tag lang von morgens bis abends dastehen
wollte dann teilt euch die arbeit gerne
auf und ich zeige euch jetzt erst einmal
wie man die dekorationen herrschen ganz
drei tage vorher mache nicht ja man kann
sie schon vorher machen und dann eben zu
silvester servieren
also klingeln ich werde jetzt
zuallererst einmal ein bisschen
dekoration vorbereiten die muss nämlich
vorher ein bisschen durch trocknen und
die könnt ihr auch gerne ein paar tage
im voraus herstellen ich habe jetzt hier
schwarze blüten passte und wer jetzt
zuerst einmal die uhr herstellen und
dafür muss ich die blüten passte weich
kneten und troll sie jetzt auf 5 mm
stärke aus das geht am besten mit zwei
drei gläsern damit nämlich ganz
gleichmäßig
jetzt nehme ich einen großen ausschnitt
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel ein
glas oder ein schälchen nehmen und das
ganze rund ausstechen oder auch
ausschneiden mit einem messer und damit
ich diese uhr später auf die torte
stellen kann muss ich jetzt noch zwei
schaschlikspieß nehmen die werde jetzt
ein bisschen aber kürzen und werde jetzt
mit etwas kleber befestigen das schützt
fahrer kleber und diese zwei stäbe werde
ich jetzt hier unten hinein stecken so
etwa bis zur hälfte
[Musik]
dann rolle ich immer noch mal gerne
drüber dann wird es schön glatt und so
kann ich die uhr jetzt erstmal durch
trocknen lassen und die übrigen blüten
passte werde ich jetzt ganz ganz dünn
ausrollen und dann kleine und große
kreise ausstechen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich noch tun und zum
beispiel solche buchstaben ausstecher
und werde jetzt aus den kreisen so
kleine zahnräder machen und zwar nehme
ich jetzt einen großen kreis und sticht
da jetzt innen den kreis noch raus und
die zahnräder außen mache ich dann wie
gesagt mit dem buchstaben
[Musik]
ihr seht dass man die zahnräder aus den
einfachsten gegenständen herstellen kann
und dass man gar keine besonderen
ausschuss dafür benötigt ich werde sie
jetzt noch ganz leicht mit wasser
befüllen und zwar deswegen dass sie
leicht feucht werden nicht nass werden
und dann kommt trockenpulver farbe drauf
und da nehme ich jetzt kristall pulver
in gold silber und bronze
[Musik]
und die einzelnen räder nehme ich jetzt
hier runter damit jetzt nicht hier
ankleben setze auf eine back folie und
lasset euch trocknen
[Musik]
der kreissitz angetrocknet das habe ich
hier ein stück schwarze modell
schokolade bereits weiß geknetet dafür
eignet sie sich auch hervorragend und
die gebe ich jetzt in meine fondant
modell ihr presse und hier vorne habe
ich eine scheibe mit der ema zum
beispiel auch kordeln ganz gut formen
und blüten passen nämlich jetzt hier
nicht weil man die blüten passte einfach
sehr schwer aus davon modelle presse
herausdrücken kann da blüten passe sich
nicht so ganz weich kneten lässt wie
jetzt die modelle schokolade muss ich
noch zu drehen und hinten dann drehen
und dann kommt vorne die corp
[Musik]
die trägt so ein bisschen
und die werde ich jetzt hier außen an
kleber
[Musik]
und hier außen an den rand klebe ich
noch eine zweite kordel dann sieht man
einfach den übergang hier nicht so arg
um den rand
hab ich hier so eine silikonform die
werde ich jetzt mit becker stärke aus
puder und da kann ich jetzt hier das der
ganz tollen ja so barock fritzl aus der
barockzeit diese tollen muster formen
und zwar nehmt ihr ein kleines stück
modelle schokolade oder blüten passte
zum beispiel und können sie dann für
mich hinein treffen
die überschüsse nehme ich dann mit einer
palette weg und die dürfen dann hier
drin erst mal aus herten
[Musik]
hier habe ich ein dünnes stück modelle
corolla da ausgerollt und daraus wenn
ich jetzt noch 22 ausschneiden und die
dann auch schon mal trocknen lassen und
alle teile die ich jetzt hier geformt
habe werde ich später mit etwas gold und
silber pulver und mit dem kupfer pulver
ein bisschen puder
[Musik]
jetzt ist noch das ziffernblatt ran und
dazu nehme ich einen lebensmittel
farbstift und der von dante ist da schon
ein bisschen an getrocknet und daher
kann ich da jetzt gut drauf zeigt
[Musik]
die dekoration kann jetzt abkühlen und
ich werde jetzt schon mal meine torten
befüllen und zu habe ich die schon
vorbereitet hier habe ich einmal zwei
torten gebacken mit 20 cm durchmesser
das war der helle rührkuchen mit öl und
da habe ich als flüssigkeit sprudel
benutzt und habe ein bisschen
orangenschalen den teig reihen gegeben
und die torte wird dann gefüllt mit
einer waldfrucht einlage und mit einer
französischen buttercreme der plan schon
vorbereitet und sagt ganz relaxed akt
mit rein gegeben
die zwei bilden halbiere ich hätte ihr
bei uns dann habe ich 4
und die habe ich bereits gestern
vorgebacken zu lassen sich ein bisschen
besser zu schneiden
und jetzt habe ich hier eine
tortenplatte bereits zugeschnitten
wetter ein bisschen von der buttercreme
drauf streichen so bleibt die torte
schön drauf haften und setzt den ersten
boden um drauf
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen buttercreme
drauf und da sind sich dann jeweils die
frucht einlagen rein und wird so die
ganze torte befüllen
[Musik]
und diese wunderschöne torte wird jetzt
von außen gleich ganz dünnen mit der
buttercreme eingestrichen vorstellig
sieht aber für etwa eine halbe stunde in
den kühlschrank
so kann sie dann nicht mehr verschoben
werden beim einstreichen und
anschließend streiche ich sie mit der
creme komplett glatt und in der
zwischenzeit für dich schon mal die
andere torte die obere torte wird eine
schokoladentorte und die werde ich mit
einer schokoladen kallasvuo und hab da
bereits vier tortenböden vorgebacken in
18 cm trotten ringen die schneide ich
jetzt jeweils einmal durch und jetzt
habe ich auch hier bereits eine kleine
tortenplatte zurechtgeschnitten und
streicher ein bisschen von meiner fahrt
peter karrasch drauf
und hier drauf stapel ich jetzt die
torte und hier ist jetzt übrigens nicht
schlimm dass das skateboard ein bisschen
kleiner ist denn die torte wird gleich
noch zurecht geschnitten
die wird so ein bisschen ihr seht ihr
gleich jedenfalls könnt ihr gerne wenn
ihr möchtet die torte mit etwas kaffee
trinken zum beispiel oder auch einen
likör zu kamera die torte ein bisschen
parfümieren und die torte wird jetzt mit
der gage bestrichen und dann auch kühl
gestellt und danach schönen
zurechtgeschnitten nicht glatt
gestrichen erst durch geschützt
[Musik]
die torte durch gekühlt und jetzt wird
sie so zurecht geschnitten dass sie in
der mitte so ein bisschen schlanker ist
das heißt eben wie so ein alter hut
also fangt ihr am besten oben an
dann geht es in der mitte weiter rein
und dann nach unten hin wieder ein
bisschen breiter und es macht jetzt
wirklich schön langsam und rundherum und
die reste hier die beweis natürlich auch
zu verraten
[Musik]
die torte zurechtgeschnitten die muss
jetzt auch gar nicht so perfekt sein
denn diese anhuth der hut ist nicht
überall gleich und die werde ich jetzt
einfach von außen komplett mit der
garage streicht
um die torte schön glatt zu streichen
nehme ich jetzt ein stück backpapier nix
braucht man könnte so ein bisschen mit
der hand darüber streichen denn an denen
stellen so gut hin
[Musik]
ich werde jetzt die torten mit fondant
eindecken die untere torte denke ich
jetzt mit einem kilo schwarzen fondant
ein und die obere torte mit blau oder
rot grün vielleicht das überlegen
bei diesem grün habe ich das so gemacht
ich habe jetzt hier 500 gramm grünen
fondant und 600 gramm grüne modelle
schokolade verknetet jetzt habe ich
einfach dieses schöne dunkelgrün und ab
sogar noch ein ganzes stück schwarzen
fondant ein geknetet und damit decke ich
jetzt die torte ein
und das habe ich gemacht weil ich gleich
für den hut noch diesen saum unten da
brauche
david suazo und da die und davon dann
einfach ein bisschen fest werden
[Musik]
nach
bei dieser form muss plätzchen bisschen
langsamer arbeiten da sie jetzt nach
unten hin etwas dünner wird
da muss man einfach jetzt gucken dass
man schön sauber die ganzen falten weg
bekommt
[Musik]
ich möchte jetzt gerne diesen abschluss
hier oben schön gerade haben und es geht
am besten menschen heute zum drehen denn
hier kann ich jetzt nicht wirklich gut
arbeiten sollte hier diese kurve drin
hab also nochmals ein flip over einmal
backpapier zum beispiel oder bugs folie
drauf und dann die zweite umdrehen
jetzt kann ich hier im prinzip ich
bestreite becker stärke dann geht sie
nicht mit kann ich hier das alles ein
bisschen runter drücken und dann wird
der abschluss und schulen gerade das
sieht man jetzt hier außen ganz gut ich
habe ich jetzt noch so eine lücke
und wenn ich jetzt hier unterdrücke dann
habe ich jetzt hier diesen schönen
abschluss
[Musik]
haben hier ein schönes warm jetzt stelle
ich die torte auch kurz raus ins kühle
und kann kurz das skateboard getrieben
das kickboard streiche ich jetzt mit
essbar und lebe ein und legt dann die
schwarze fondant decke drüber
auf das skateboard wenn ich jetzt noch
die eu machen und zwar auf römischen
ziffern und die habe ich jetzt hier
bereits ausgestochen und klebt sie mit
essbaren kleber auf die schwarze die
untere pforte setzt jetzt schon mal auf
das skateboard ich lebe jetzt auch nicht
fest da ist die torte so wie du nicht
transportieren werde aber falls ihr sie
irgendwo hin mitnimmt dann am besten und
bis hin nach strom
[Musik]
jetzt möchte ich die untere torte gerne
dekorieren und die soll aussehen wie
eine schultafel und ich mal mit kreide
drauf und für die kreide optik habe ich
weiße pulver fahre hier und die könnt
ihr für mission mit wasser oder zum
beispiel rum oder wodka und dann mit
einem pinsel drauf mal wenn ich schreibe
ist ein paar sachen formale dinge drauf
die fürs jahr 2017 geld mitbringen und
glück gesund halten
[Musik]
die unsere tochter kippte den
kühlschrank gestellt
und weil jetzt die obere torte noch
weitermachen und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier ein stück vom band und modelle
schokolade bereits dünn ausgerollt und
nehmen das jetzt hier auf ein stück
folie und zwar muss ich den hut machen
also ich habe bisher nur den teil wo der
kopf heben wo auf dem kopf steckt jetzt
kommt noch dieser rahmen dann kommt da
ein bisschen kleber druck kann ich jetzt
hier die torte draufsetzen und ich mach
das jetzt so damit ich nicht also ich
jetzt auch erst aufstehen können und
dann die trotte drauf aber so muss ich
jetzt nicht darauf achten dass ich die
torte mit ich drauf setzte nämlich einen
tortenring ein hut mache ich bin der
hutmacher und werde jetzt hier mit
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich so kleine röllchen aus
küchenpapier und kann die jetzt unter
die torte also unter dieses bändchen
versetzen und kann so im prinzip die
torte formen wie ich möchte also dass
der roten bisschen realistischer
aussieht
[Musik]
die torte stelle ich jetzt so auch in
den kühlschrank und werde aber dann die
torte erst morgen zusammensetzen so kann
alles noch mal schön fest werden ich
kann hier in der zwischenzeit aufräumen
und dann wird alles fertig gestellt
[Musik]
heute stelle ich die torte jetzt fertig
ich habe jetzt hier die grüne torte den
hut und habe etwas grüne und schwarze
pulver farbe und wird die torte jetzt
damit so ein bisschen puder
das sieht ein bisschen echter aussehen
das heißt hier so ein paar keine flecken
alt aus
damit ihr langes band ausgerollt aus
modelle schokolade und von da ich ja
beides gemischt und jetzt werde ich das
hier einmal mit dem cygnet ausschneiden
jetzt riecht einmal um und schlag dann
außen das ball nach innen
so habe ich keine unschönen übergänge
nicht wieder um und legt auch so ein
bisschen entfalten
[Musik]
das muss gar nicht so genau sein aber
ich lege mir schon mal so hin
denn ich werde auch dieses jetzt mit
etwas kristall pulver und roter farbe
streichen
sonst einfach eine intensivere farbe
[Musik]
jetzt schreibe ich ein bisschen s-bahn
kleber draufgeklebt es fenstern um den
hut
[Musik]
hier vorne klebe jetzt noch die branche
an
jetzt kann ich die torten zusammensetzen
beim stapeln von torten ist immer ganz
wichtig dass die untere torte
unterstützt wird denn die obere hat auch
ein eigenes gewicht und könnte in die
untere einsinken
deswegen nehme ich gerne kickoff sticks
oder zum beispiel solche trotteln stäbe
die man aus kunststoff hat und die kann
man ganz gut zurecht schneiden
rundhölzer aus dem baumarkt gehen aber
zum beispiel auch und die torten stäbe
die steckt man jetzt hier rein führt sie
auf die entsprechende länge und zu hat
die obere torte genug nie so hat die
unteren rate genug stabilität um die
obere etage auszuhalten
[Musik]
kommt hier oben noch drauf
und dann kann ich die torte mit den
zahnrädern noch fertig dekorieren
[Musik]
ein
so jetzt wird die torte angeschnitten
und ja heute schon sehr weh dass ich sie
abschneiden muss ich weiß nicht wie ich
an der tat
jedenfalls habe ich mir jetzt hier vorne
ein stück ausgesucht das mache ich jetzt
hier
wenn man jetzt die torte servieren
möchte fragte ich wahrscheinlich wie
schneide ich denn diese dauere das brett
runter und so weiter
das heißt entweder könnte es so zu
machen dass er die obere torte zuerst
und dann das brett unter der oberen toto
wegnimmt und dann die untere anschneidet
oder ihr könnt eben ganz praktisch die
obere auch auf die seite setzen das
sieht ja dann auch ganz gut aus
abmelden den hut nehmen dran und die
andere torte davon die arbeit der
letzten zwei dem weg was vielleicht wenn
ihr vorsitzenden für das kommt mir meine
vorsätze noch mehr zeit mit der familie
verbringen und manchmal das handy
einfach auf glaubte versetzen handy aus
war ja auch mehr zeit mit der familie
wir haben es zum glück auf kamera ist
jetzt gerade gesagt besserer mensch
werden nach das kann es doch gar nichts
du bist so wundervoll wenn die kamera
aus deshalb stehen aus gegen
teilzunehmen
nein
ja
mit meiner kamera lässt nur kleine
stücke essengeld denn die fertige hoch
also ich viel motiv trocken
die schau wie schön saftig ihr seht es
hier am tag eine creme reingemacht ja
der untere also den unteren kurven bin
ich geschmacklich fast noch besser
gekocht mit drin
und wie schmeckt was mich gesetzt
erinnert kennt diese lebkuchenherzen an
den teichen league ko und herzen in apps
ja die untere tor darfst du gleich
probieren sobald wir noch ein paar fotos
gemacht haben wirklich ok verriet
wünscht danach machen sowie citrix sich
deswegen durch keine zeit zu bewegen
wo steht dem vorhaben im märz fertig ich
finde ich mal ins leben formt das ist
eine andere geschichte
also falls ihr diese torte nach machen
wollte stehen die genauen mengenangaben
natürlich auch meinen blog auf sallys -
blog.de und wir wünschen euch jetzt eine
schöne silvesterfeier falls ihr feiert
last krachen aber nicht so sehr
und ja was kann man noch sagen alles
gute fürs neue jahr gesundheit wünsche
ich euch erfolg und seine familie
frieden wünsche ich mir aber eigentlich
die ganze welt genau bei dem was alles
passiert kann man eigentlich noch
frieden und gesundheit filmchen also
viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal bis dahin dürfen
die zuschauer wissen dass wir morgens
und dass wir morgens um acht uhr motiv
konnte probieren guten appetit gleich
gehts frühstück der fiskus keine
ausnahme dass die zum ersten januar
morgen zum achten mal torte essen
vielleicht und wenn sie dann
[Musik]